continuamos con el vídeo anterior sobre
fluidos y dijimos que la conservación de
la energía nos dice que el trabajo que
pongo en un sistema o la energía que
pongo en un sistema es igual al trabajo
que sale del mismo sistema oa la energía
que sale de este sistema lo que
significa que w o el trabajo de entrada
es igual a w s o el trabajo de salida o
que la fuerza de entrada por la
distancia de entrada es igual a la
fuerza de salida por la distancia de
salida ahora me permítanme reescribir
esta ecuación de aquí y dividirla en sus
respectivas áreas y reemplacemos las e x
y las s por 2
nos quedan f1 sobre a 1 ahora imaginemos
que de este otro lado
que será elevado por una fuerza de
salida efe 2 que es esta que estoy
indicando aquí así que nos queda
efe 1 entre a uno por uno por distancia
1 todo esto va a ser igual a f2 nuestra
fuerza de salida entre el área 2 x
área 2 por distancia 2
esta cantidad f 1 sobre a 1
la fuerza entre el área se define como
presión la presión es fuerza sobre una
área dada p 1 y que es a 1 x de 1 pues
es igual al volumen de 1 así que escribo
todo esto
como b1 b1 presiono 1 volumen 1 igual a
la presión 2 por el volumen 2 y que es
lo que sabemos acerca de estos dos
volúmenes pues que ambos son iguales así
que podemos quitar o dividir ambos lados
por los volúmenes y nos va a quedar que
la presión 1 va a ser igual a la presión
2 aquí les indicó en el dibujo presión 1
aquí en este lado va hacia abajo y va a
tener un resultado de si yo dibujar aquí
otra
otro pistón pero este se va a elevar voy
a dibujar aquí la presión 2 que va hacia
arriba
y esto para que no sirve
lo que esto nos dice es que si tenemos
cualquier presión externa sobre un
fluído
pues debido a que un fluído no se puede
comprimir esta presión se va a
distribuir en forma homogénea en todo el
fluido que es lo que acabamos de mostrar
usando la ley de la conservación de la
energía y todo lo que sabemos sobre
trabajo ya esto se le llama principio de
pascal toda presión externa aplicada a
un fluido se distribuirá homogéneamente
por todo el fluido otra forma de verlo
lo vamos a mostrar a continuación
digamos que tenemos aquí un tubo que da
hacia un globo y digamos que hacemos
esto en la estación espacial
internacional es decir no vamos a tener
gravedad aquí va a estar flotando y
digamos que aquí tengo una pistón y el
globo va a estar lleno de agua y lo que
nos dice el principio de pascal es que
si yo aplicara algo de presión alrededor
de todo este globo vamos a ponerlo con
otro color
aquí aplicó la presión
externa
esta se va a distribuir de manera
uniforme por todo el globo
este se va a expandir uniformemente y
esto espero que les ayude a comprender
mejor este concepto aquí como vemos
estoy aplicando la presión y lo que va a
pasar al aplicar la presión es que todo
se va a expandir de manera uniforme en
el globo con un líquido recordemos que
los líquidos no pueden comprimir pse así
que esto es lo que sucede ahora vamos a
regresar a lo que habíamos dibujado
anteriormente este contenedor de forma
peculiar yo vamos a dibujarlo de nuevo
aquí en una parte es más angosta otra
entrada es más ancha y va a estar lleno
de un líquido
esta es una máquina simple
vamos a terminar de llenar esto del
líquido porque digo que es una máquina
simple
porque si yo
aplicó una presión externa en esta parte
aquí
pues voy a tener la presión de entrada
va a ser igual a la presión de salida
pues se distribuye uniformemente presión
de salida
así que voy a escribir esto como la
presión de entrada igual a la presión de
salida y la presión que es pues es la
fuerza entre el área así que esto
también lo puedo escribir como fuerza de
entrada
/ área de entrada
que es igual a pues ya saben se pueden
imaginar a la fuerza de salida sobre el
área de salida
vamos a hacer un ejemplo digamos que voy
a aplicar una presión de entrada
de vamos a escribirlo aquí presión de
entrada de 10
pascal un pascal es la unidad de presión
y que significa un pascal bueno vamos a
escribirlo con las unidades desglosadas
de lo que es un pascal tengo presión de
entrada igual a 10 newtons sobre metro
cuadrado
newton por metro cuadrado es la unidad o
es lo mismo que un pascal y digamos que
mi área de entrada aquí le voy a
escribir en otro color
área de entrada la más angosta es de dos
metros cuadrados
vamos a escribir lo mejor aquí dos
y también sé que mi área de salida a s
es más grande esta va a ser de 4 metros
cuadrados
entonces ya sabemos cuál es la presión
de entrada y ahora quiero saber la
fuerza de entrada vamos a escribir la
fórmula de aquí en la presión de entrada
que damos que es igual a la presión es
igual a la fuerza entre el área entre la
fuerza de entrada entre el área de
entrada la presión yo estoy
estableciendo que es de 10
así que escribo 10
igual
a la fuerza de entrada que es lo que
quiero conocer es mi incógnita entre el
área de entrada que está si la conozco y
es de 2 metros
así que despejó aquí y queda que mi
fuerza de entrada va a ser igual a 20
newtons ustedes pueden checar las
unidades para que vean que efectivamente
quedan newtons ahora mi pregunta es cuál
va a ser la fuerza de salida con cuánta
fuerza empujará el sistema hacia arriba
pues tengo que me presiones salida igual
a la fuerza de salida sobre el área de
salida como las fuerzas las presiones
perdón las presiones de entrada y salida
son iguales aquí escribo 10 entre mi
fuerza de salida que es mi incógnita y
el área de salida que en este caso es 4
así que mi fuerza de salida es de 40
newtons es el doble como pueden ver aquí
voy a escribir mi fuerza de entrada
efe
es de 20 newtons lo escribo aquí abajo
20 newtons y como resultado aquí en la
salida voy a tener una fuerza
fuerza de salida del doble de 40 minutos
en lugar de los 20 minutos que fueron de
entrada por eso digo que es una máquina
simple porque está duplicando la fuerza
de entrada